[Musique]
bonjour Johanna bonjour Thomas bonjour
Julia on commence ce journal avec ce qui
s'est passé hier soir du côté du
football le match entre Nice et
Marseille qui a délivré du être du sport
et ça finit par un fait divers hier soir
c'est donc le match
OM - Nice qui était arrêté 1h30 après
que les supporters ont on entend quelque
part c'est les réglages du début
le monde lutte contre un nouvel ennemi
mais pas de panique capitaine dévoué le
super héros grand cœur est là avec son
équipe et les super pouvoirs de la
science médicale il combat les mensonges
sur les vaccins dans une pièce de
théâtre éducatif à San Bernardino en
Californie et il désarme son ennemi
mortel en persuadant les familles de se
faire vacciner est-ce que la vaccination
encore une fois va permettre d'endiguer
l'augmentation des cas de variant Delta
les prédictions c'est pas mon style pour
l'instant ce que je vois c'est que c'est
pas les pays les plus vaccinés qui en
ont le moins ce qui était le plus
vacciné de tous c'était l'Islande
l'Angleterre Israël c'est reparti
exactement il s'aime quelque part le
doute oui
le doute
les Français
ils ont besoin de certitudes et alors tu
n'as pas le droit de jeter le doute sur
les vaccins parce qu'il y a pas de doute
à avoir vous prêchez comme un
prédicateur au Brésil un homme qui a été
interpellé alors qu'il s'apprêtait à se
faire injecter une sixième dose de
vaccin ouais un accroc
deux mois entre mai et juillet et puis
il a testé tous les parfums si je puis
dire un deux doses de Pfizer une
d'AstraZeneca 2 du vaccin chinois
coronavac c'est dans tentant d'obtenir
une sixième dose qu'il a fini par être
repéré par les autorités nous ce qu'on
voit c'est ce que j'ai présenté c'est
que globalement par rapport au nombre de
gens qui sont diagnostiqués le
pourcentage d'hospitalisation le
pourcentage de réanimation et de 30% de
celui des deux variants précédents donc
qui ne sont pas vaccinés donc la maladie
moins grave je pense que ce qui va se
passer ça va être une obligation
vaccinale parce que trois cadeaux parce
que ceux qui sait notre exemple le plus
critère vous voulez ça sauve des vies en
fait c'est là où je comprends pas
pourquoi qu'on me démontre que ça sauve
des villes
qui ont ce modèle de restriction de
liberté de tout vaccination
des gens que nous avons réanimation
n'ont pas été vaccinés Régine devait
recevoir la visite de son neveu à
Toulouse mais finalement après quelques
échanges par téléphone il en sera
autrement et m'a dit que il y avait pas
de sanitaire qui ne voulait pas et je
lui dis bah écoute moi j'avoue que ça me
pose un problème pour moi je t'accepte
pas parce que tu n'es pas vacciné on
s'est fermé la porte on se parlera plus
sanitaire tu as le bracelet bleu moi je
connais quelqu'un qui a refusé qui a dit
mais attendez vous avez pas me mettre un
bracelet moi je propose qu'on se met
quelque chose à l'oreille vous avez
comme les comme les comme les habits les
vaches
bravo c'est bien une fille on a pas
encore le prénom on commence à partir le
prénom on a le prénom Karine bien sûr
[Rires]
fausse alerte ce n'est qu'un jeune
couple en train de fricoter
alors je suis venue avec ma chienne
polka ils sont en de super bien à
merveille un Yuki
[Musique]
à côté d'Olivier mais je sais pas est-ce
que vous vous connaissez
ma moitié
c'est marrant ça ça pourrait donner une
idée de jeu un jour serait des coups
je lance ça j'ai pas de carton j'ai une
tablette mais ça fait plus mal arrête
pas arrête ça
arrête ça
arrête arrête
[Musique]
désolé je croyais que c'était un vrai
combat la tranquillité d'une plage en
Espagne perturbé par des
narcotrafiquants ils sont deux à bord de
ce petit bateau poursuivi en mer par les
autorités la scène ahurissante c'est pas
s'il y a quelques jours près de la ville
de Grenade les touristes présents ce
jour-là ne se sont pas contentés de
filmer ils ont plaqué au sol l'un des
deux trafiquants qui tentait de s'enfuir
sac à la main l'autre sera arrêté
quelques mètres plus loin par la gare de
civile
sans vous endormir et bien votre cerveau
vous dit je suis immobile l'oreille dit
que ça bouge et donc là c'est le vomito
et c'est la catastrophe
dans sa voiture quand même au cas où
merci à mes parents pour leur bon
conseil
vous avez aussi des fruits personnels
d'esthétisme en cas de victoire 20000
euros vous devez partager ce moment
dégoûter mais bon si je gagne 20000 €.
je fais l'épilation définitive oui c'est
ça c'est ça
serait vraiment sympa
c'est bien quand même cette fois
[Applaudissements]
et donc du coup de toute façon si vous
regardez pas ça n'a aucun sens bah oui
c'est le dernier lancer
votre cadeau et votre cadeau c'est
l'indispensable boîte de petits pois
toujours utile dans un placard quand il
n'y a plus rien dans le frigo avec la
boîte de petits pois les carottes ne
sont jamais cuites si tu as un petit
message pour noter les spectateurs la
caméra est à toi un téléspectateur sur
ton groupe plein de graisse de la télé
va voir les spectacles vivants parce que
là sinon franchement enfin la vie qui
est ta mère avant même la passe depuis
merci merci merci merci